I have completed 43 years serving this
nation I would work for every type of
military aircraft that is flying in this
country in some form or the other I have
worked with every major integrated
defense program
whether it is electronic warfare program
or whether it is integrated guided
missile development program of late SRI
Dr Abdul Kalam I am a recipient of best
citizen of India award in 2011. I also
have received Glory of India award in
2013. I was selected for the Rajiv
Gandhi National Excellence award and I
have been a nominee for padmasti twice
hello
I am Commander yvv Prasad I did a
program in the recent past having
enrolled myself for the post graduation
in the cyber security
I am deeply satisfied
with my Association
with simply learn and they offer an
excellent flexibility for study and
online learning their course is very
comprehensive the hackers mindset how to
defend the Hacker's mindset and the
various technology policies and the laws
which are there in the Cyber today the
cyber warfare program with reference to
how to defend in number of ways I did
not do it for any kind of resume
building or for any career purpose I did
it purely for my own learning and simply
learned supported me all the difference
personal must actually go through this
particular certification process and
especially for those who are working in
the software field in different sector
there is no system today which is not
software software loaded so therefore
there is a responsibility cast on all of
us to ensure that the systems are well
protected never hacked by any kind of
foreign Nationals and eliminations
particularly and we have to be very
careful in developing the software to
such kind of Standards it's essential
that the entire software development is
completely cyber security safe and I
recommend to all the defense personnel
to actually Avail this particular course
to Simply learn today the Warfare is no
longer only missiles and the gunshots
the Warfare is today very imminent in
the form of cyber warfare
and that can stop us
that can completely stop the entire
nation
think of all the software systems coming
to a halt whether it is banking whether
it is the transport sector whether it is
energy sector private sector how do we
defend ourselves that becomes important
so it is not the guns it is your
knowledge in the cyber security that is
going to defend the country in future so
I recommend strongly that people become
aware of the essentials of the cyber
security and have their requisite
awareness
[Music]